What do you think about those vibration plate machines? Are they good for keeping the lymph system
moving to help with circulation, to move core strength by doing exercises on them?
Or any other real benefits to help? Excuse me, I had to take a drink there.
The vibration plate machines are great. So typically those are called
vibe plates. You're standing on this machine and it's vibrating. The benefit of it is
multifold from a lymphatic system standpoint. It's causing what's called muscular
fasciculation, which is these teeny contractions of your muscles. So actually standing on a vibe plate
for five minutes is like walking for 20 minutes or something like that. So it is great way to
contract your muscles, which thereby will help with lymph flow and the simple vibration is going
to help with lymph flow. Help with your circulation can build core strength just like you said,
especially if you're doing exercises on them. Also is a great stimulation for your cerebellum.
Your cerebellum is the back part of the brain which controls all your frontal motor cortex
function goes through the cerebellum and cerebellar issues can be the very common. So the only
thing that I'd say you'd be careful with them with is that you just go slow. Are there any
contraindications to my machines? Yes, if you have like metal hip replacement or knee replacement,
it could be too much vibration. It could irritate that. It could possibly dislocate that. You have to
be careful with that vibe plate issues. If you have any braid issues, frontal cerebellar issues,
you have to go really slow. Maybe only a minute at a time on it. Even at that you should start
really slow anyhow because it is a pretty strong cerebellar stimulation. So go real slow in starting
and they can be great machines. They can be great for your braid and they can be great for all sorts of
things.